THEY ARE ALL DUE BETWEEN NOW
AND THE END OF JUNE.
>> Bret: NEGOTIATIONS
CONTINUE THIS WEEK ON NAFTA.
THE HEAVY HITTER HAVE GONE
HOME.
THERE APPEARS TO BE LITTLE
CHANCE OF ANYTHING
SUBSTANTIAL BEFORE THE
DEADLINE SET BY THE U.S.
RICH EDSON HAS THE LATEST
TONIGHT FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
>> THERE APPEARS TO BE
LITTLE PROGRESS IN TRADE
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES, CANADA AND
MEXICO.
JUST THREE DAYS AHEAD OF A
CONGRESSIONAL DEADLINE.
A SOURCE CLOSE TO THE
DISCUSSION SAYS THERE ARE NO
MEETINGS SCHEDULED THIS WEEK
BETWEEN U.S. TRADE
REPRESENTATIVE ROBERT
LIGHTHIZER, THE CANADIAN
FOREIGN AFFAIRS MINISTER AND
MEXICAN ECONOMY MINISTER.
THE TRIO MET THROUGHOUT LAST
WEEK IN AN ATTEMPT TO TRY TO
SECURE AN UPDATED VERSION OF
THE NORTH AMERICAN FREE
TRADE AGREEMENT OR NAFTA.
>> NAFTA HAS BEEN A
HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE DISASTER
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
>> TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
FORCED TO NEGOTIATION TO
KEEP THE U.S. IN THE
CONTINENTAL FREE TRADE
AGREEMENT.
NEGOTIATORS SAY THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES ON AUTO
MANUFACTURING, THE SYSTEM
FOR SETTLING FUTURE
DISAGREEMENTS, AND THE U.S.
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE AN
VERSION OF NAFTA.
TO PULL ANY DEAL THROUGH
CONGRESS, HOUSE SPEAKER PAUL
RYAN SAYS HE NEEDS AN
AGREEMENT SOON.
>> WE WILL SEE IF THEY CAN
GET IT DONE BY MAY 17TH AND
GET TO PAPER TO CONGRESS AND
HAVE THIS VOTE IN DECEMBER.
>> WITHOUT IT HE SAYS THE
ISSUE WOULD FALL TO THE NEXT
CONGRESS.
ONE VOTERS WILL CHOOSE IN
NOVEMBER'S ELECTION HE IS.
DESPITE THE CONGRESSIONAL
CALENDAR MEXICAN AND
CANADIAN NEGOTIATORS SAY
THEY REFUSE TO SUBSTANCE
OVER PRESSURE.
>>
THERE ARE MANY
WHO WANT THIS TO STAY IN
PLACE AND PEOPLE ADVERSELY
AFFECTED BUT THAT'S STILL
HANGING OVER OUR HEAD.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SPOKE
TODAY WITH CANADIAN PRIME
MINISTER JUSTIN TRUDEAU.
THE PRESIDENT UNDERJORDAN
THE IMPORTANCE OF QUICKLY